So based on the previous connect and the feedback that we have shared for the engineers, we are working on that at the same time. The information that I shared in the performance spotlight for the individuals very mentioned.
work distribution should not reflect the percentage of work that they have done and the relevant tickets. So I was actually reaching out to Arkadi too because he was supposed to share me what information he wants to see in those slides. So I did not get any reply from him so I had to.
Dharam.
Akshay.
proceed with the old way that I used to do. So this is just one thing that I wanted to give the heads up before I present the negative thing. And the training milestones that you asked for. So I have that to complete list with me.
Okay.
Okay, yeah, alright, alright, yeah.
and I will share that with you right after this call.
Okay, perfect. Thank you.
So that we are on track with that. And yeah, that's about it. So before I go into the presentation deck and discuss other details of the past week, I would like to know from you, how was the past week with the engineers and how did they do?
I have no insight of that. I think it's an Arkadi because Arkadi works with them directly. So, I'm not sure what was the effect of those, but in overall we can say even if you train.
One line, if you study one line, it's definitely has effect on on on the technician work, but I I I don't know, I I would say it's on Arkadi, so let's wait for him. Hey, Sarbjeet.
We did already.
The.
Oh.
to see what he says because I'm not working directly with them.
Kam.
All right.
Apologies, Rita. Sorry, I was just talking to Chester a few minutes back.
Kour.
Mm-hmm.
How are you doing?
I'm good, yeah.
Good, doing well, thank you.
Yeah, yeah, in a side note, uh...
I'm not sure it was a it was a discussion between your team and Tyson about somehow swapping branch with someone else. Okay, you're aware about that.
Kip.
Why do you want to swap that that attack with us?
Are they complaining about the that that technician?
Yeah.
I'm being honest, Reza, I'm not aware because I wasn't part of the discussion. I believe Amit and Lee had a word with Tyson specifically, how they would like to strategically do the placement for the resources.
Mhm.
Ohh, I see, and they mentioned to me that you have a...
Yep.
Another resource from another country, like you do have Philippines technicians as well.
Yes, we do.
Oh, okay. Okay.
I'm not sure what the plan is, but I think for Ranch we're gonna go and do the swap stuff with the with the Paris and see what happened. I'm not sure about the technician name. Who's that technician name?
The.
I think it's Karthik.
I.
How we can spell it? G.A.
It's KKARTICK.
KTICK Kartik Okay.
How long is it joined to your company or to Parry's company, I would say?
He had been with Jason Scott. I think it's been more than six months now.
Mm.
Okay, just so he's happy with him, right?
But he's happy with all of his technicians, not specifically with.
Ohh, he's happy with everyone. OK, OK, OK, so my, my, my, it's a good point for Vange to find the Perry's to work, yeah, OK.
Yeah.
Yep, yep.
No, I would like to utilize this time, Rita, to quickly walk you through the training plan that I have. Although I will share in the email, but I can utilize this time to share with you.
Yep.
Let me know if you're able to see on screen.
Yeah, see your screen now.
Thank you. So, the emphasis was on start with the high impact topics first, but since some high and medium impact topics were falling under a specific domain, so the trainer had to build the environment from scratch, so he chose to
categorize it domain-wise and put high impact and medium impact and even low impact topics into relevant domains so that we have a clear picture which topics he would cover date-wise and how long it will take to complete the entire training. So if I...
Hi.
That makes sense. Yeah, it makes sense.
If I scroll down, so it will take until the end of September, so we are looking at the entire Q3 here.
Ohh, OK. So, by the end of the September, we're gonna end up with the full training plan with two things.
Yes, including hands on.
OK, good point. So they started from active directory, then they're going to go on Azure Intra.
Yep.
Okay, user device in 365. Yeah, these are good stuff.
OK, so the sequence is like, so the curriculum of the course is based on the sequence, right?
That's right.
Okay, change it to SharePoint.
65, change tune.
SharePoint gonna happen on next month, which is good. I think by the end of the next month, we would train them for Active Directory Azure and 365 Exchange in Tune and SharePoint.
Yeah, which is perfect. Can you scroll it down?
Support.
You really, OK, compromise detection. I think we can, yeah, we can swap RDS and security time if it is possible, 'cause you know, these technicians are mostly working RDS, then security part.
Correct.
Even, yeah, even you can move security to the end of the course.
Okay, I'll ask the trainer to put security towards the end and I think from SharePoint we have RDS desktop and general issues, right?
Yeah.
Yes, yes, desktop, desktop health.
At work device will be blockers to take that, but in theory direction.
Yeah, and for desktop support, yeah, it's gonna happen on August and September, right?
Yes.
All right, I think it's good. It's good. Because you know, they already know how to support a desktop and it would be a quick review for them. But if they can focus on the 365 stuff, yeah, it would be better. Okay, I think it's good. Just move the security to the end, move everything up.
Wednesday 8 and.
We would be good with that.
Short.
I will do that.
And, uh...
Regarding July 1st, so you were more inclined towards utilizing Kobe Day for the training. Since July 1st is not a holiday for ITBD in India, rather it's July 3rd. Before I go into training.
Mhm.
Side, um, since we are aligned with engineers getting trained on, you know, July 1st, so that means it's the working day for them, July 1st.
Yeah, you can, you can consider the working day, but focus on training, totally fine.
Right. I would have to check on this piece because although it is working day for ITBD by design, so is a working day for trainers. He would have his slots booked for other trainings too, but I will check. That day would not be limited to just an hour.
Yeah.
I see.
Look rather two, three, or four, as much as possible, so that we can place the maximum of it.
Mhm.
Yeah, yeah, exactly, because you know I can assign some tasks to them, but I would rather have them to be trained than assign some off-the-shelf tasks to them to work, so the more obvious that we can train them.
The.
Heather.
Okay.
All right.
Any other questions on the training?
No, Paul, you should, you replied to my email about the recording sharing, totally fine, yeah, acceptable, because it might be in your privacy to not share, which is which is fine, yeah, but I'm not sure if you're...
Trainer can share the curriculum, detailed curriculum of that, like, let's say, or or any any item that they studied during the course, just for our information, even if it is a high level of stuff, one level down then that the file that you share.
Just for us to make sure that the topics that we want covered there. It's totally fine. But if it isn't in your privacy, again, it's fine. Don't worry about that. We want to see the results.
Yeah, sure. So, this is one thing behind engineer, when they are going to the train sessions, the trainer is building everything from scratch, including server installations, you know, promoting the DC. So, while he is performing the actions and training it to the individuals,
Yeah.
Ohh.
Is it?
It's a bit complicated for him to make side notes as well for high-level information. Hey, Dorian. So yeah, I would respectfully say no to this request. At the same time, since we are more aligned towards a genius getting the required knowledge and utilize that knowledge for the betterment of our customers.
Ohh.
I.
Nice.
Kip.
So this is what we are aiming to.
Yeah, Kour.
The.
Thank you.
Okay, Karine, just want to give you a heads up about the decision that recently made about lunch. We're going to swap lunch with one of the technicians from Paris PU.
Or.
Yes.
Okay.
Who, who directly works with GSL? So, yeah, so, so the technician name is Kartrick or Kartrick, yeah, yeah, yeah, I think he is based on their experience with it.
Karthik.
Kip.
I.
This technician, as per Ashish, just as happy with him, just want to swap, so suppose my branch works for them, because you know there are different type of process, there are different type of expectation, so we're gonna, we're gonna swap.
Both and see what happens.
Okay, sounds good.
Yep.
So.
Right.
Yeah, we used to have a gentleman named Karthik back when I was with MedEx, so the name familiar with me, so that'll be yeah.
Paul.
Alright, alright.
Before I jump into the presentation, is there anything else you want to share?
No, from my end, no, okay.
Ashish.
Kip.
I'll go ahead and share my screen.
I.
Is it?
Yep.
Thank you. So, starting with performance spotlight for lunch, this is from June 8th till June 14th, where we have received 2 surveys for lunch and both were positive. So, it's 100% for lunch for this duration. During the board reviews, it was identified that there was a ticket to...
409326 that could be categorized as sort of a project ticket because it was it was involving 20 users where a bunch had to work on minor changes into the email address of the user. So he successfully did that. There is a ticket number, 2409387, where we received.
Positive feedback from the users documented in the day itself, and next we have is a bulk distribution for lunch, where his triage percentage is thirty-six. User facing issues were 8%, problem resolution regarding application and systems they were 18%, then...
User set up an onboarding for thirty-one percent.
He was able to answer 3 calls in the last week. So we have this number as well listed here.
Ali.
Hey, Team.
Yeah.
Hey.
Any questions there, Rita?
Yeah, no, I have no question 'cause, you know, about these numbers, we already we already spoke about this, yeah, we came over.
Yep, yep.
Okay, similarly for JASP, although his percentage is lesser than the last week, but it's still at 53%, which is apparently more. On basis of my assessment, Tuesday then Thursdays are the days when JASP does the triaging.
And so, ticket and flow was was on the higher side during two during those two days, because of which his overall percentage has increased more than we expected.
Yeah, that's right. And one of the good thing about Jasp happened yesterday, I'm not sure, Torin, you involved with, yeah, you were involved with on that. Jasp was able to catch one of the security stuff that happened for one of.
one of our client, suspicious activity that happened for a client, and he could catch it right at that time. So that was a great job that he did.
Yeah, plus he, plus he followed our process, so knowing that it was before 9 A.m. we don't have our security team on yet, so we do have a process to follow. He executed all the changes that we needed made before then, and then got to pick it up to our security guys to follow up. That was excellent, very happy with that.
Yeah.
Thank you, Rita. Thank you, Dorian.
Mm.
Okay, next slide is, I hate to present, but I have to. This is again regarding the process site where one of the tickets regarding time sensitivity, I think it was signed by Jas to Rihanna, where he did message Rihanna that
But.
This ticket can be taken by her, however they.
was no punishment. So we have cascaded this to entire team and they have been instructed to do not apply just on the DM, but rather in the chat where people can be held accountable.
Ohh.
What?
My observation, correct me if I'm wrong. Team had been following these steps. It is just one odd instance that happened yesterday, and I mean, I accept that it did happen, but at the same time, we have to be considerate that, you know, JASP.
and rest of the team, they have been following the process diligently and we just shared one of the examples too. So yeah.
Yeah, yeah, it is totally fine. It happens, but one of the things that we are working on is revising our triage process, because I know they know how to triage, and that is the learning point for the new hire.
What?
to understand the importance of triage for us, but Tori, me and Arkadi are working on a new document to a new process to explain everything about triage and the importance of that and how.
They can handle it because we know we can have two different approach. The first one is the one that we are already on it. We triage a ticket, assign it to technician, and it takes some work on the issue. And if something happens for the ticket, back to the...
very first of, very first day and see how we did triage, what was missed there, and then say, okay, if we could start it over, we would do it in this way and we triage it in that way. But what I'm thinking is we should catch the issues that.
At the beginning of the ticket, which is the triage part, so we're gonna, we're gonna, we're gonna focus more on the triage process. It would be a new training for our technician, and yeah, we're gonna help them to understand better about.
Rick.
the expectation that we have for triage, but totally fine. Yesterday it happened and I jumped in and I spoke with Jas. It was only a training point. We are happy with him.
Yes.
I appreciate it.
Right, next we have is Jimmy's spotlight performance, where he worked on email outlook issues, either onboarding and offboarding, device connectivity, and phishing alerts on email. Although his significantly...
Higher, as compared to one, the other my calls last week. The matrix site for Jimmy is not visible to us as of yet, because his name is not in the report I get every week from Jeremy. So, I'm in communication with Jeremy to add both Jimmy and...
Mhm.
Paxton to the list that we have visibility about this.
Yeah.
See, OK.
Okay, sure.
Similarly, for Paxton, his work distribution says that 30% of the work was on either onboarding and mailbox and email outlook, they were from 19%. Phishing was 7% and device and hardware ratios 23%. And he also answered 7 calls in the last week.
Sure about the call answer, because I see his name a lot in the panel. He grabbed the phone call right after the call, coming to our queue. So it should be more than this. I'm not sure, but it, yeah, it's only my intuitive.
Yep.
Yeah, I kind of feel like there should be more than that too, but yeah, because he's pretty quick on this.
It's a bit.
Conviction about his call answering, but...
Okay, how about once? Do you see same trend for once also? Because what I showed you was three. You did not say anything for him.
Mm.
Hmm, Purvesh, yeah, really? Yeah, Jasmine, Jimmy, or I got a call. Paxton start working, and I see his name a lot. Yeah, at least recently I saw his name.
He'll answer calls, not not as not as frequently as Jasper, Jimmy.
Rick.
All right, next I have is the utilization trend for Jasp, Wanch. I think they are on the higher side. Being the older ingenious, obviously, they have more visibility, but Jimmy and Paxton, they are gradually climbing up, and soon they'll be able to match the numbers for the other two ingenious.
Pass was 95. Yeah, can I go back? Sure.
Ankur.
Yeah, sure.
Yes, 91.
How is that positive of 91% B level, 13% non B level? It's more than 100, right?
Yep, so the time he entered into the tickets, six hours, what he entered was non-billable time. So on a basis of calculation, it's 13%. I know the sum is more than 100%. So at times, you know, engineers have extended their shifts, so they are not just sitting.
Yeah.
For 9 hours, uh, at times they reduce the on the break timings also, and then the shift, so which explains why it's more than 100%.
Ohh.
Oh yeah, because you know the way that we calculate the bill level and un-bill level is totally different. We consider we consider the total of the working hour and just calculate the bill level based on the total hour. But yeah, yeah, I think you considered 44 hours or...
Forty hours for the for, yeah, Kashyap.
40 Kip.
Any other questions?
Yeah.
No.
Kip.
And this is the tickets data for them. Jazz was able to close 16 tickets, once 29. Jimmy and Paxton, 10 and 12 tickets, respectively.
Hey.
With me and share my screen.
Uh, Kip.
And regarding the non-billable site, Razdan, one thing that came into my mind is I think Jas was on call last week. So I only got to know this morning that he was on call last week. So I'm not completely aware about how this process works.
what he's expected to do when he's on call.
Now, we have it, we have it on call shift for our weekend, because you know I have three different teams under service desk. One is Helpdesk, another is Field, and the last one is team.
I.
and help this team, including the field technicians. We do have an obligation for weekend. It doesn't mean that we need them to actively work on stuff. We need them to be on call for
Anything that happens, because I do have another team in India, they are working 24 7. They cover, they cover after hour for us as well as weekends. So if something happens and they cannot fix it, they're going to ping.
a chat that we have, including Helpdesk shift, escalation shift, and security shift. So depends on the subject of the ticket. If they need help, someone jump in. So I would say it's not.
It's not actively working. It's only being on call.
So, yeah, so we we shouldn't expect a lot of utilization, be able to stop for them on those days.
OK.
They can, yeah, they, they, they, they can go do their stop, but if we need them, we're gonna ping them.
Kip.
Right, and if and if during this time any if an emergency happens or anything of that sort happens, so they are found.
This should reach to their team. We say, yeah, it's OK. I cannot, I cannot be there. I cannot handle this ****. It's totally fine, because you know we we do have at least four people during the weekend and they are back, they're backing up.
Everything, yeah, I mean, like most of the things are handled with our twenty-four 7 people, so in rare case we need them, so like something happened for a client, it's critical incident, we need might we need more hands to communicate with client to.
to handle the tickets or something like that. But it's rare. It's rare.
All right, I got it. And one last thing, I think Arkadi reached out to Paxton.
Do we have a need of changing Paxton's shift timings?
Uh, was it yesterday?
Was today? I, yeah, it was yesterday. I'm sorry, it was yesterday.
Yeah.
OK, Paxton works 11 to 11 to 8, right? I think in our last our our yesterday meeting, we agreed that.
Yep.
We agreed to move packs into 1030 or 10. I'm not sure about that time. Can you recall it, Karine?
Our caddy reached out to him to discuss yesterday. He's going to look into it. Yeah, it was just we talked about pushing some of that support a little earlier in the day because we're getting a lot more morning stuff. Plus for utilization purposes, having two texts on after 5pm, it's a little bit difficult to always make sure that they have enough work.
Yeah.
on their plate to work with. So that is the plan. And I know Arkadi was discussing with Paxton, but I don't know the outcome of that.
Mhm.
Oh yeah, let let me let me find his timesheet. It's good to share with you.
Because.
Okay.
Kip.
So the reason why I was discussing this, Razdan, is changing shift timings of the engineers depends on external factors such as logistics and the availability during the requested hours. So I have to ensure.
I see.
that we have the required transportation facilities available during this time. So, and even if they don't, then we would have to rearrange everything. So it takes close to 7 to 8 days to say a yes or a no. So at times, Paxton,
Ohh, I see.
Aman.
and other engineers are not in the state to agree or say yes or no to it. So I would, you know, if any such requests, you know, they are directed through us, that would be more convenient because if everything is sorted, we would let you know and then the engineer.
Mm.
Ohh.
I like, yeah, yeah, I agree, I agree. Yeah, sure. Moving forward, we do that. So, for now, for packs, then is it viable or you need to?
I need to check, I need to check this with the D.
Kip, Kip.
Kip.
Yeah.
All right.
As you know, as you know, yeah, for some of the technician that we have, I'm not sure Paxton was there. We do have a time slot every day at six or seven, or it was 7, 7 to 8 P.m.
Right.
The workload is low, we do not have a lot of ticket, so they are looking for some tickets to to to add to their utilization, but if we move them a little bit up to like to 10:30 or to 10.
I.
They have enough workload to handle.
S.
1030 Eastern is what we are eating. 11.
1030, 1030 is there, yeah.
Okay.
10:30 Eastern, OK.
I'm not sure which time Arkadi told you, but I think we agreed on 1030 or 10.
Let's see if I can frame the conversation.
Is it, yeah, Torrent, or if maybe Khattri can just email us, that would be better.
Yeah, sure. Yeah, yeah, moving forward, we're gonna we're gonna formalize it to send email to you first and then speak with the technician, or maybe it's on your side to speak with technician and handle everything. Yeah, yeah, I agree with that.
Absolutely, yes, so I would, I would wait for Arkadi's email on the practice, and then we'll take it from there.
Sure.
Yeah.
Thank you.
True.
Anything else, Rita?
Nothing from my end.
Dorian.
All good for my answer. No, we're all good from here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Support.
I'll check in with our Khattri after.
The.
I know I missed the start. I know I missed the start of the call. Hello, everybody. Thank you again for jumping on. It's good to hear. I'm hearing good and better things sprinkled into the discussion. So I'm really, really happy to hear that. That's great. And thank you for sharing those. Was there, I know that there was some discussion.
Yeah.
Bye.
Right.
around some movement that Tyson and I started having. And I just want to know, because where Tyson and I left it, was he was going to talk to you all and one of his other groups and do some internal coordination.
Mhm.
Did you guys have an update for me on that or are you waiting on an update from me on that? I guess is how I'll put it here.
Yeah, it happened just before our meeting, 'cause another our our meeting with Tyson just before this meeting. I'm gonna I'm gonna speak with Jessel 1st and see what's his plan for that swap.
OK.
Mhm.
And then we can reach to you to coordinate the all the hardware stuff configuration, 'cause you know bad they they should join, we we we we do we we should do some technical things before swapping those those guys, but give me.
Yeah.
Yeah, give me a couple of hours. I'm gonna work with Jessel, but yeah, yeah.
So, sounds good, and no problem. I wasn't intending to rush. I just knew that this was a topic of discussion, and I wanted to make that we were on the same page as far as who's waiting for what. If I had information to share, I wanted to make sure that I was getting the.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'll let you know that.
Yeah.
Hi.
All right, perfect. Thank you.
Yeah, and and absolutely right, right? We want to manage this just as we would with any other swap or replacement. I'm sure Tyson shared the goal here is to is to is to make, I I guess, run thoroughly.
Sure.
evaluation against the team member. What if there's a better, you know, it's not, you know, there's a better opportunity that they fit better with, right? And I know you guys have been so incredibly considerate about trying to make sure that the engineers are taken care of and give them opportunities.
Yeah.
So I knew you wouldn't take any issue with that. It just gives us that extra little bit of due diligence to say, oh yeah, this person actually gets much better here, or yeah, still not a fit. Let's go ahead and move them out, and then ITBD will have our own internal processor.
Mhm.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, exactly. Yeah, at the end, it's gonna happen, 'cause you know, even if we say we don't wanna work with Ranch and you, you should look for another job for him, or say, let's swap them between views and see what happens.
Yeah, well, and that's the thing, right? The goal is to somebody, if somebody has spent a little bit of time learning MSP Corp overall, you know, maybe there's an opportunity to sit there, right? That knowledge share that's happened, even if it's not directly benefiting your pod.
Okay, thanks.
Yeah.
If it directly benefits the org as a whole, then that's still a win for all of us, right? And it gives you the opportunity to do the same if we see, you know, if Tyson and I are talking, he's like, hey, this person's advancing beyond the need of this BU.
Thank you.
Practice.
Yeah.
Mhm.
and you guys have an open position at some point, then we get to say, oh, okay, how would they fare on Razdan spot? Maybe, maybe they'd be doing really well over there on a BCCS. So, yeah, so just glad that we're in those discussions now, and you just keep me posted on what's needed. Keep us, the group was, did I want.
Yeah.
What's needed, and we'll make sure that anything from our side, as far as communication.
and coordination on the logistic and physical front takes place.
Yeah.
Yeah, cool, cool. And yeah, I think I, yeah, I'm in the process of getting approval for two more technicians, but it should be from another spot that you have, because they mentioned that you have.
Right.
technicians as well and we're going to work on it. Yeah.
We do, we do. I has that been? Are there are those positions open up with us yet? Do you know? Have those been opened with Karine?
Uh, I'm working on that for it, but once I get after a while, I let you know.
Fortune.
Okay.
Oh, yeah, please. If you want to offer the heads up, and I know that between Amit and Ash and Keith, we all have a lot of current, so I'm sure we'll hear about it there too. But if you want to give myself a heads up, I can go ahead and make sure that I'm talking with our Pre Sales and bench team that
Mhm.
Yeah.
We're doing stuff because I do work across both sides, right? Across the community. Yeah.
Uh, okay, so it's not a new department. Previously you had that one, right?
Correct, our Philippines our Philippines group has existed for about two years now, now with MSP Corp, it will be it will be new to MSP Corp, right?
Um...
Ohh, so no, no one from that group is working, give them a speaker. OK, OK.
Not as of yet, not as of yet, but, but it's worth noting, we do have several clients, several partners of ours who leverage skill from both sides of both regions, so this is new for us either, right? We, yeah, yeah, so the question's really just gonna be...
Mm.
I see.
Yeah.
Alright.
Pre.
Making sure we're finding talent that, just like, just like in India, talent that we leverage the skill sets that they have appropriately, right, and and find our ways to make up for any any advancement or development that those.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Team members need as a as a plan, yep.
Hmm, I see.
Okay, and what's the delta between those groups? Either is fine for us. We're just looking for someone who is able to handle our stuff. I'm not sure about what's the delta between those groups.
So it.
In general, and remember, these are generalizations, and there are, of course, people who live outside of these generalizations. In general, you're going to find a higher technical skill set easier to come by in India, in general.
Mhm.
Okay.
Yeah.
That said, in general, you're going to find very customer service slash communication focused team members in Philippines. Like those are the generalizations of their skill set strengths, right?
Mm.
Ohh, I see.
No, I see.
That said, we've got a number of people in India, many of whom you interact with, who are very communicators, right? Very strong at customer service and follow-through. And similarly in Philippines, we try to find people who are strong technically.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Mhm.
right? So it really is just a question of what people bring front and center as part of their like natural inclination and culture, right? But if you're saying that the new positions are going to be, you know, with Philippines in mind, that's fine.
Hi.
But we can still, if you, if you want, we can still source from both and just see who wins the race, right?
Yeah, yeah, I think I, as I said, either is fine for me, as you know, I have some...
Yeah.
Skill set, I wanna I wanna know who can cover it, and I do have some job description for them. I'm looking for someone to handle it, so I'm just curious what what was delta explain it, but just overall it's general, it's not specific.
Kour.
Pre.
When?
When you send it along to current, forward it to current, and she's going to open it up with us, send it my way, and I'll give you my thoughts, my initial thoughts as well, based on the JD that you pulled together.
Oh, yeah.
Kip.
JD is the same. JD is the same as what we have for Paxton, Jimmy, or where it's for helpless.
Ohh.
Okay, okay, good to know. All right, then I'll take a look at that. Yeah, but you know, a little from our perspective, like I said, we've got many partners who leverage across both seas, and part of it is because the holidays
Mm.
Schedule tends to be a little different, and that helps with coverage. Part of it is these little nuances in culture that the add color and and sometimes really, really nice to have that you know that that difference in diversity among the among the staff.
Yeah.
Eyes.
Anyway, OK. Thank you. Let's see what happens.
Yeah, right.
And.
It's on, guys, it's on.
Yeah.
Okay, thank you guys.
Thank you.
Talk.
Yeah, just before I let you go, the only request which I have is we have received the monthly CSAT for JASP. It's pending for the rest of the three engineers for one for other engineers. So, Ashley, if you could please resend the CSAT survey, that would be helpful for us too.
Yeah, sure, sure, yeah, do that.
Appreciate it. Thank you.
Yeah, thank you. Excellent. Yeah, nothing else for me. Thanks.
Okay, thank you guys.
Right, thank you so much. Have a good day.
Guys, have a good day. Bye.
So much more.
Pleasure as always.
Cheers.
Bye bye.
Yeah.